no I think it should be somebody in
energy and it's got to be because that's
that's the big problem where they're
putting out the billions of dollars to
try to solve the energy problem and it's
got to be boy who would be the best
person for that I mean I I know I'm not
energies not my field but I'm trying to
think like who's the Dave Dave Clark of
energy Dave Clark is one of the there
was actually six people that invented
the internet and Al Gore probably gets
mentioned it's one of them he's one of
the guys and he runs a bunch of NSF
grants right now and he's forcing it's
interesting because the Academy plays
here in industry the idea the idea that
you know professors get tenure for
proving somebody else wrong and so
they're not collaborative he's forcing
collaboration among the groups that he
funds and this is very brightness in the
race maybe you guys think about getting
him on but somebody like that but that
is really up to date in many different
energy fields and has sort of spent a
long time in unfortunately it's not it's
not my area so but I would say that
that's the person that you I mean come
on you gotta solve the energy problem
and and you know you look at the four
biggest companies in the world well
three of them are oil companies and
there's walmart in there too it's just
it's cute you know it's built in Somis
it's it is our economy and so sort of
getting in there you go so you might
need a you know somebody else that can
also run the politics and and doesn't
have anything supposed to need a
maverick in there that's willing to you
know throw his career at the problem I
mean I think a lot of people are willing
to now it's so bad but I don't have I
don't have a name unfortunately and that
can be you know you can be fooled if
you're not from the field itself is my
scary news